(crowd talking in background)
(thumping)
Think you're in the wrong line, compadre.
Uh, nope.
Doesn't seem like you're
dressed for Strong Force Squad.
Uh, actually, I am, bucko.
There is no parrot in Strong Force Squad.
Yeah, there is!
The parrot is always just off
screen so you can't see it.
What, how can you tell?
No, not...
There is no way!
All the screaming and the explosions
that happen in that scene where Zapfon
and Power Claw fight the
Insidious Sink in New York City,
that would scare a parrot.
Well, I'm sure they got
a professional parrot
who's been trained to be brave.
(scoffing)
Oh!
so the parrot wouldn't
squawk during takes.
Oh!
No parrot is
that professional.
Or that brave!
I don't know what to tell you!
Read the original comic books, okay?
Zapfon and Dr. Struggle,
they have a whole conversation
at Strong Force HQ
about how there's always a
parrot just out of frame.
There is no
off-screen parrot!
Blasphemy, liar!
(crowd yelling)
Desmond Howe?
Nice cosplay of the parrot
that's always just off screen.
Thank you, Desmond!
This is impossible!
He did not!
No way!
This is a set-up!
Desmond, I love you!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa
Hey!
You two, you're coming in a little hot.
Have a Snickers.
(wrappers crinkling)
Guess it is possible
there could be a parrot
that's slightly off screen.
Good cosplay, man.
There you go.
(chuckles)
Also, never disagree
with a celebrity again.
It's very rude.
Because we're famous.
(crowd yelling)
Thanks, Desmond!
Thanks for the tip!